hey I'm Carl ritger
um and I'm at the national snow and ice
Data Center and The Institute of Arctic
and Alpine research at the University of
Colorado Boulder and what you see here
is the red outline is the outline of the
Upper Colorado River Basin so that shows
snow cover fraction or snow cover
percent uh today and then over on the
right side here is sort of a historical
graph that shows
um in the gray area sort of the
interquartile range or the middle 50
percent along with the driest and
wettest years at the top and the bottom
in the median year in the middle
um with the blue line here and this
point at the very end showing this
year's conditions and I should say that
these conditions for the wettest and
driest are chosen uh from the years with
the wettest and driest Across the
Western UF s not specific for this Basin
so we could have a slightly lower or
higher year on those but they're pretty
good proxies generally so you can see
that you know today on well this is
usually a day delayed the way we got the
satellite data coming in but March 7th
if you kind of go back you know we do
our analysis up to March 1st but the
snow-covered area summarized over all of
the Upper Colorado
is you know at a maximum we've got you
know more area than we usually do you
covered with snow and one thing we can
do as well is we can overlay Point
observations of snow water equivalent so
we have sui here change and snow water
equivalent which would tell you about
storms in the last 24 hours and then the
percentage of mean so what equivalent
and I usually use that bottom one the
percentage of means so I'll click that
on now you can see this color bar has
two colors on it one for the snow cover
which is the underlying map and one for
Suite which is on the top there
and um you know what you what you see
here is that you know on the western
portion of the Upper Colorado into Utah
there we have very high values and this
color bar only goes up to 150 percent so
we're sort of saturating our color bar
there you do see sort of on the Eastern
portion of the Upper Colorado here just
west of Denver that there are sort of
more normal conditions and you know one
or two stations with slightly below
average conditions and as I mentioned
earlier down to the sagre de Cristos
there's values that are below average
but those are outside of the Upper
Colorado they happen to be in the state
of Colorado
um so so yeah this kind of allows you to
see both of those things at the same
time
um the other things we can look at and
I'm going to use this configure
variables to sort of add a bunch of data
to the map here so uh you can view a
whole bunch of variables snow covered
days is basically a duration of snow
cover
snow radiative forcing tells us the
impact of dust and snow on the snowpack
it melts faster when there's more sorry
dust and carbon when there's more dust
and carbon on the snowpack it melts
faster and then snow Albedo is just that
brightness of the snow so now I've sort
of set those so the top graph here was
the snow cover
and then we have snow covered duration
or snow covered days here so you can see
that
um you know we're doing well above the
75th percentile again this is a summary
graph uh showing you know compared to
the previous 22 years from the satellite
record
Colorado gets a lot of dust uh in the
San Juans so we have the radiative
forcing map here uh you can see that
right now I'm looking compared to the
averages we're sort of at the we've got
the cleanest snowpack or the least dust
uh impact from you know on the on the
snow energy balance and if you look at
the snow Albedo as well you sort of see
that same thing with high Albedo values
meaning it's reflecting a lot of the
sun's uh solar radiation
um so yeah that's kind of the the set of
data that we have available on here we
bring together the satellite derived
maps of snow cover snow cover days
radiative forcing and Albedo along with
the sweet Point measurements from the
snotel stations